how does it look right now let's be
honest la is actually fine believe it or
not not like new york i mean what i'm
hearing about new york is insane and
during the pandemic la had kind of
fallen into a bit of that with there was
just a
far greater number seem seems of
homelessness camps that had popped up
everywhere
lining the streets i mean where i live
in venice it was the whole area it had
just become a homeless encampment
basically did it feel unsafe to you
walking around and everything
uh yeah well we didn't you know i'm from
living in la we couldn't walk around
much yeah we were we're like told stay
in our houses and never leave that's
true um yeah i mean it was for the most
i mean during the height of the pandemic
when we were in lockdown it was pretty
unsafe so there was a lot of the you
know we saw the looting and the
destruction of like santa monica got
burnt down i mean it was just it was
really bad in a lot of areas and it was
unsafe there were a lot more people um
there was a lot more violence i have an
app on my phone that notifies me of all
the violence that happens around citizen
app that that notifies me of all the
violence that's going on around me and
it definitely higher rates and it was
always something really bizarre like
woman with a machete and then yes and
that regularly somebody with a machete
that wasn't even like a one-off that was
an often occurrence
so we're seeing definitely a higher rate
of violence certainly in the height of
the pandemic it got a lot scarier and a
lot of people around me that never
considered owning guns
were really seriously discussing buying
guns in fact they must have because the
gun sales went through the roof even in
places like california so
um it's definitely there's a an increase
in theft we're seeing a lot more home
you know robberies when people are home
still burglary yeah even yeah up until
now we're still seeing a higher rate
of theft uh for sure and i think
probably violence i haven't looked at
the stats but i would say
i do see you know just
anecdotally in the app more and more
people seem to be getting assaulted when
walking or but it doesn't feel that
unsafe
typically i mean we know you know don't
you know take off your jewelry don't
wear don't bring your fancy bag or
whatever you know whatever it is right
so don't leave anything in your car
um people are being more cautious when
it comes to that kind of thing so i'm
curious somebody like you could go
anywhere right you have an independent
show you have the dream right you built
this show up you can work from anywhere
you want in the world yeah anywhere
really as long as i have good internet
there you go
why do you stay in la what is it about
it is it is it really the weather
because i know the weather is
extraordinary but what what is it really
that makes someone like you stay you're
saying like don't carry your nice bag
those are i don't even have a nice bag
by the way but if i did i wouldn't carry
it right right why live in a place where
you couldn't carry a nice bag around or
you'd have to think about that if you
have the ability to go wherever you want
well i don't know where that place would
be right now i feel like crime is up
everywhere but
specifically why i don't leave and i get
asked this question all the time is i do
love la i mean i love la it's great
there are a lot of crazy things about it
but i grew up in idaho where it was
crazy as well in its own way so i feel
like anywhere you live there's there's
an element of crazy that's just going to
be there uh i don't know you know
right whether it be from the right or
from the left like you have to put up
with something no matter where you live
um but i do love la i love the weather i
love the food i actually really love the
people as well
uh my family's there so that's another
thing okay my mom my grandma my mom's
side of the family are all there my
husband is also his whole family's there
and he's actually born and raised in the
area so for him it's like
leaving is uh you know that that would
be a much bigger thing for i've lived
all around the country
so have you ever lived in new york i've
lived in new york yeah i still have my
new york number i'm trying to sell it if
anybody wants it nobody wants it anymore
nobody wants anything seven numbers i
think well that's true for some reason
that is true people do like the 911 i'm
getting rid of it though so but yeah i
lived in new york i've lived in texas
austin texas is where i lived before
going to l.a i've lived in indiana
illinois
um idaho utah yeah i mean northern
california southern california i love
southern california like i always
thought that that would be the place
that i would go and i would like
everyone like retires in florida i said
not me i'm going to malibu i don't care
and then the pandemic happened i watched
what happened in new york i watched what
happened in california and i had i had a
baby and it really changed everything
for me because i said i cannot i now
need to think about schools i now need
to think about things a little bit
differently these policies these
mandates what's going to happen and i
just don't trust these very blue
in particular that does make me pretty
nervous because we are trying to have a
child right now so that does make me
that that definitely
frightens me a bit of enrolling a child
in california school district where
you know the state mandated that even
private schools would make the kids get
the vaccines for example and i'm just a
big proponent of medical autonomy i
believe i will make the choice for
myself and for my children
you know with all the information i i
want to be given all the information but
i want to make that choice
and you know for them to mandate it even
in a private school so you have no
option except to home school and even
then they're making it difficult because
then if you want to enroll your child in
extracurricular activities they would
then need to be vaccinated for example
so hopefully they drop that type of
thing but the fact that they were even
able to go there during this i have to
think you know 18 years of a child's
life going through school what are they
going to do in the next 18 years i don't
know
that does make me definitely very
nervous if you like the short clip you
can catch another one here or you can
catch the full episode right here
[Music]